we're here with our dear pal tiki barber
all right rossi your story all right
well martha stewart living reports a new
study asked thousands of married
americans over 35 this question what do
you do when your spouse is out of town
and you have the whole house to yourself
a majority of americans said they watch
all their tv shows that their partner
hates yeah which makes a lot of sense to
me because there's
that's what you do at night when you get
home together you watch the show right
right so what's a show you watch it your
wife doesn't want one so i love sci-fi
so i'm currently watching expanse
whenever she's out tracy's out but i
refuse to watch shows so tracy will go
upstairs with about an hour before
bedtime and start watching and just like
that
oh yeah downton abbey oh god and as soon
as i walk in the room i'm like turn it
off
really turn it off we gotta watch
something that we both want to watch
turn that off i feel like i could marry
your wife i watch both of those i mean i
watch a little bit but i can't all the
time yeah i can't do it all the time
you're not alone most men do not want to
watch and just like that and downton
abbey yeah straight men i should say
thank you very much for clarifying okay
the second most popular answer they
feast on all the food their partner
doesn't like to eat when they're alone
um and the third most popular is that
they talk to themselves which i know i
know you do right i do talk to myself on
the legs you know what i like to do what
do you say
well it depends um sometimes i say the
thing i wish i would have said sometimes
i say the thing i need to say like later
that day or that week i'm kind of
pumping myself up sometimes i have
conversations with like a faceless man
in the mirror
um and i flirt
huh
um
okay
me yeah all right good for drew well
that's not crazy at all
all right finally we've all been in the
position where you have been so kindly
invited somewhere that you simply don't
want to go
metro reports that there is a foolproof
way to get out of any situation or party
they say the main thing is to make it
quick fast and sweet specifically they
say that you should try a thank you
sandwich which there is you nestle in
the know between the two thick slices of
thank you bread
for example
oh my gosh thank you for inviting me i'm
afraid i have a conflict that night and
can't come but have fun and thank you so
much for thinking of me yeah
i've said that to myself in the mirror
too
i
i think that's actually very well-worded
this is a great prompt i'll tell you i
like to do this method but i go a little
further because i so i compliment them
profusely like oh my god that sounds so
much fun oh what a great time oh it's
killing me i can't go i have a thing but
you have fun and i'm so jealous send me
a picture oh nice you know what i say
i have six kids i got something else to
do oh really i have six kids my daughter
has cheer oh my other daughter has a
ballet uh my kid has a game i got a game
i gotta go to that's really a good
excuse yeah but they're actually it's
real yeah
and then i'm just like i just think oh
what a good dad and like the onus is
completely off of you that's right
even if the game was two days ago
well my daughter has a dance recital
tonight and i couldn't be more proud i
was going to ask you to dinner oh oh
well see i've already told you i can't
go the best
best excuse ever well tiki
wfan sports radio and back here
to discuss all the things that you and
your wife are about to be up to my
beautiful other will be here oh we can
wait we'll be right back
[Music]